hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
Mark Ellis flying solo for this week as
my beloved co-host Jacqueline Coley Is
On Assignment currently the assignment
today is twofold well one you can check
out upcoming tour dates of mine at Mark
Yellowstone live including Las Vegas
next week and when we talk about what
we're getting geared up for in the fall
obviously if you listen to this show for
any period of time you know Jacqueline
and I are huge football fans so we're
about to kick off with the NFL season
with college football but there's also
some art things that we're very
passionate about including on September
21st the new Star Wars live action
series and or drops on Disney plus and
so we figured what better topic to talk
about today than the Star Wars live
action TV series that we've already been
blessed with on streaming services and
looking at their rating according to the
tomato meter and audience score so here
is your Star Wars show rankings and
again this is just live action Rebels is
great Clone Wars is awesome we're just
doing the live action ones and the
Mandalorian averages out to be the
number one seed 93 fresh is his average
score for seasons one and two we got one
season so far the book of Boba Fett and
one of Obi-Wan Kenobi it is Obi-Wan
Kenobi that takes second place at 77
which is also certified fresh and then
the book of Boba Fett bring it up the
rear but still fresh at 66 interesting
to note the only one of the three shows
that has a rotten audience score is the
book of Boba Fett which is almost fresh
it's fresh adjacent at 57 I used to live
one street over from Beverly Hills so I
was Beverly Hills adjacent and then
sometimes depending on who you're
talking to you just drop the adjacent
and you just say I live in Beverly Hills
so book a Boba Fett I'm allowing you to
say a you live in fresh Town well
someone who always is a the mayor of
fresh town for all I know he does so
much great work with his Endeavor that
he created with his buddies Heroes
reforged you can catch that Empire on
YouTube Adam hawavek is here Adam I say
it's an Empire but it's really more like
Heroes reforged is like the first order
without the downside it's all the good
stuff it's all the organization all the
technical achievements but without any
of that you know murdering innocence and
using the dark side of the force I mean
at least that's how you see it you don't
know what happens behind the scenes now
do you Mark I've never been invited to
watch a taping so I don't know all the
bickering the the retiring to trailers
for hours I don't know how all that
stuff goes but you seem like you're the
best of friends on camera it's a
bloodbath sometimes I won't lie oh you
know how it is man I I certainly do you
do reviews on YouTube with one other
person for a long time and you do get to
bickering but it really you know
watching you all talk about heroes talk
on Heroes reforged does remind me of my
schmo's no days with Christian harloff
simply because you can really tell that
you guys the disagreements are great but
you you also see eye to eye as far as
where the tone of the show and and that
is if you're in alignment with that then
it actually makes such fertile ground
for you to have disagreements about the
art about what's better and that's sort
of what we're here to talk about today
is these shows that we all want to bring
a positive spin to because there's
always so much back and forth on social
media and negativity and the fan base is
always torn apart it seems but at the
end of the day you have three Star Wars
live action TV shows so far and they are
all fresh on the Tomato Meter which is a
good thing so if I I was to give you
your ranking it's Mandalorian Obi-Wan
Kenobi book of Boba Fett according to
Rotten Tomatoes but I ask you is Rotten
Tomatoes wrong great question you know I
I went back and forth with a couple of
these titles but I think for me for the
most part it's actually correct in my
opinion
um for me the Mandalorian for sure is
the top spot I think that one has been
the most consistent for the last two
seasons in terms of its quality
storytelling action the fun that the
show has and then I think from there you
know you really have to for me at least
personally just as a Star Wars fan as
someone who worked in visual effects for
years I have to kind of start breaking
things down from story tone production
quality and all that sort of stuff and
while I do think you know Obi-Wan does
Edge out Boba Fett in some ways I think
it's like pretty minimal for the most
part but just in the general sense yes I
do agree with this with this ranking I
have Rotten Tomatoes as being wrong here
I I agree that the mandal DeLorean would
be number one in my book by a not a
sizable margin but there's some
breathing room there and then you get to
number two which I would have as the
book of Boba Fett I just found Boba Fett
and the Mystery behind this character
that we all really fell in love with
with very minimal screen time to back it
up to get into that backstory and the
way that we flash back and Flash Forward
I thought was so well done Obi-Wan
Kenobi is again some show has to be
third place it's not necessarily
detriment but when you're making the
list that's the problem with doing these
things is that somebody's got to be
bringing up the rear and unfortunately
uh one of my favorite Jedi of all time
is the last kid picked in DodgeBall for
this list because Obi-Wan Kenobi I just
and I'm on record as saying this and
maybe I'm just becoming an old man
yelling at Clouds but I love how
precious my timeline has always been
with the classic Trilogy and it feels
like we're infringing upon that
territory and that again I go back to
breathing space a little bit where we're
just cramming a lot out of Canon into
these times when I still want my Obi One
to just be that crazed wizard that is
just walking and just kind of you know
so out of practice and out of shape
um but I did like a lot of what Obi-Wan
Kenobi brought to the table so we'll get
into all of these and what our feelings
Behind These rankings are right after we
spend some time at our neighbor's house
that being Tim Ryan our expert review
curation manager here at Rotten Tomatoes
he's going to tell us what the critics
were saying at the time of release of
these three shows going all the way back
to 2019 ah we were all so young Tim take
it away
[Music]
with him the made for TV Ewok movies The
Clone Wars Lego Star Wars and the
granddaddy of them all the Star Wars
holiday special
none of these will be discussed on
today's segment instead we're going to
focus on the three live-action Disney
plus Star Wars series before we jump in
a quick note about overall scores they
factor in both season level reviews and
the Tomato Meter scores for individual
episodes here we go from 2019 and 2020
the mandalorian's two seasons are fresh
on the Tomato Meter with an overall
score of 93 percent and they have a 92
percent audience score the book of Boba
Fett's one season from 2021 is fresh
with an overall score of 66 percent with
a 57 audience score and Obi-Wan Kenobi's
one season is fresh with an overall
score of 79 and has an audience score of
65 so what did the critics have to say
in a fresh review of Obi-Wan Kenobi Zaki
Hassan of the San Francisco Chronicle
wrote this show demonstrates all the
ways the Star Wars Universe can revisit
familiar faces and places without
feeling like a simple Retreat however in
a rotten review of the finale of The
Book of Boba Fett James whitbrook of io9
wrote it's never been clear that boba's
original status as a compelling design
in search of a character is something
Star Wars is still struggling with after
all these years so that's a rundown of
the recent Star Wars TV series let's get
back to Mark a man who has never gotten
me anything for Life day thanks a lot
mark back to you folks there you have it
I mean again there's a reason why these
three shows are fresh according to the
Tomato Meter and now we get to get into
the TV talk of it because we hear this
music
when you first heard that Star Wars
might become a TV show in some capacity
were you enthusiastic were you hesitant
as far as I remember I think I was
pretty enthusiastic about the idea now I
can't exactly remember how much we knew
about the show when they first announced
that they were going to do one like I
don't know if we specifically knew that
it was like a Mandalorian series or not
but I think because at that point I had
kind of finished my my time in visual
effects and I had seen
just how much it had advanced in the
time that I was doing it I had a lot of
high hopes for what it potentially could
do and then I think once I started doing
some digging and figuring out that they
were going to use some of the tech that
they did on like Jungle Book but it'll
be better and then that you know Tech
got even better with things like The
Lion King I thought okay then this
series probably has something to offer
otherwise I don't think that they would
do it I don't think that they would put
the Star Wars franchise at such a risk
by creating a TV show that cannot live
up to what the movies at that point were
so and I think this show probably what
must have been announced like what 2017
2018 so that point we had already had
the force awakens we probably were very
close to having the Last Jedi so I think
at that point I was pretty on board with
what Disney was offering in terms of
what they thought could be something
that could live up to or surpass or at
least get very close to the quality of
the movies so I was pretty enthusiastic
yeah it was almost like you were
following in George Lucas's thought
process because Lucas famously did not
want him make the prequels didn't even
want to think about him until he knew
that the effects would catch up to where
his creative genius was and so that's
why it was such a gap between 83 with
return to the Jedi in 99 with a phantom
menace and then once you have this I you
know I you because you did work in
visual effects and folks listening and
watching Adam has worked on some of the
biggest movies of all time you've seen
the movies that Adam has had a hand in
with his Magic Touch is there a point
that you can because we can so easily go
back and look at Jurassic Park as that
was sort of the thing that George Lucas
was visiting his buddy Steven on set and
he said oh wow I can tell the stories I
want to tell now is there a similar
moment in visual effects history that
would have been the conduit to let TV
shows have that storytelling ability is
there one moment that you can pinpoint
in time is there a show that you say oh
wow I didn't realize that we could do
that on television or on a streaming
service that's a really really good
question and a curveball because I did
not ask you to think about this at all
leading up to right now so I apologize I
think I think two shows for me because I
here's to be totally truthful I didn't
watch a ton of Television growing up and
the television that I did watch was
something was stuff that did not require
heavy visual effects but two shows that
definitely stick out to me are
Smallville which is the Superman origin
story and heroes on NBC yeah Heroes on
NBC was a really impressive show
considering that it was a obviously a
weekly series in the old school format
of TV 22-23 episodes and it did have
some pretty ambitious visual effects for
a series that was not based on anything
it was not based on anything uh no
Marvel no DC no Star Wars so I think in
the 2001 to 2007 era you know I think
more shows started doing more visual
effects so I think somewhere around that
point I think Studios and and audiences
started to realize oh we could do things
a little bit more ambitiously on
television we don't have to just rely on
cheap tricks or you know
shortcutting stuff like we can actually
do visual effects and then obviously the
explosion of the arrowverse I think has
also been a huge contributor to that as
well when you're watching Star Wars
stories on the small screen which is
what we're focusing on today I do find
the storytelling it lends itself more to
that Western vibe that it seems like
everything is going for now where a
western is going to be a lot of downtime
there's going to be a lot of gradually
revealing the layers of who a character
is and what their real intentions are
and to pair that with the familiarity
that we have in this galaxy I think that
that has been one of the big selling
points for me about really all three
shows because the book of Boba Fett is
so closely tied into the DNA of the
Mandalorian and then Obi-Wan it's
further back in time but it also you
know Obi-Wan Kenobi maybe that's the
reason why it's number three for me Adam
is because I'm so connected with Obi-Wan
Kenobi and Darth Vader since I was born
that it's almost like there's no way
that you're ever going to be able to
live up to all of those expectations but
I've never seen this Mandalorian guy
before I've never seen a baby Yoda
before that's cool everybody deserves a
grogu and then with book of Boba Fett we
we knew so little about Boba Fett that
it's like yeah that became appointment
viewing because what the hell is this
guy about now that he has emerged from
the sarlacc pit and is trying to sort of
rebuild himself I think because I have
such an attachment to Obi-Wan Kenobi he
first of all he's my favorite character
probably in all of Star Wars oh wow okay
so when that show is announced I was
incredibly excited for that show like
just seeing you McGregor walk on that
d23 stage I like almost lost it he's so
good at saying hello there and just
getting us to just turn into puddles of
Goo I mean I'm so good at it yeah he's
so good at it I mean he's yeah he's been
doing it for so long now so I think that
also definitely in influences my opinion
and my ranking of the shows my
anticipation I love Boba Fett don't get
me wrong I think he was such a cool
character I think the prequels maybe
kind of made me no I don't want to say
less excited but it didn't do anything
for me to get me more excited for the
character so when he showed up in the
Mandalorian I was like this is awesome I
love this this is so cool what a great
way to reintroduce him and then the show
kind of was like an up and down a little
bit of like a roller coaster emotional
roller coaster for me because there
definitely were moments in it that were
like amazing incredible got me even more
hooked into the character but then there
were stuff that I was like okay it's
just kind of moving along whereas with
the Kenobi series I kind of felt like I
was invested the whole time because I
care about this character so much so I
think a lot of that also has influenced
kind of like where I rank these two
shows yeah you buy into the character
immediately because you know Obi-Wan and
it's the guy who has played him before
yeah um when it comes to the mandal war
and that's the top ranked one on the
Tomato Meter and also in both of our
minds what what is the is there an
episode is there a scene that you can
point to in either season one or two uh
that that really is why this show turns
you on so much for me it's funny because
I didn't immediately pick up at the end
of the first episode of season two that
that was Boba Fett and so the episode
ends and it's this now famous shot of
your kind of behind Boba Fett just off
to the right and he and he pops into
frame right as before we Fade to Black
and I just remember thinking wow that
looks like a menacing present and then
the credit and I was like wait a minute
wait and I rewind I was like that's
freaking Boba Fett so that was
definitely an Alzheimer for me what's
the Alzheimer for you as far as a scene
or a sequence goes in the Mandalorian
season one or two that is that that's a
good one the the Boba Fett reveal is a
really good one because I remember at
the time there were rumors you know as
there are always circling the Tamara
Morrison was going to come back and then
it was kind of unconfirmed and then it
just kind of like disappeared Into The
Ether and I forgot about it so then when
that reveal happened at the end my jaw
hit the floor so hard because I couldn't
believe that he was back in the Star
Wars universe so that was an amazing
moment but truthfully the very first
episode of the Mandalorian hooked me and
I was just so gobsmacked by how good it
looked and how much it lived up to the
quality of the movies and up to that
point the whole sequel Trilogy had come
out so we had all three movies that had
already come out or it was actually no
no sorry we had the first two we had
Last Jedi and Rise of Skywalker was just
about to Premiere so up to that point
you know I was really impressed with the
look of the movies and I knew some
things about the volume technology not
as much as I know now but so I was
intrigued by the whole idea and process
of how they were making the show so even
just from the first frame of Mandalorian
walking across this like snow filled you
know walkway into this bar I was like
okay I'm really vibing with this like
Western feeling the music that
louboutson would made and then by the
time you get to the end and you see the
IG robot and Boba Fett or Mandalorian
taking out this whole town of of
villains and then leading into the
dramatic moment of the revelation of
baby Yoda I was I was hooked so it all
it took was the first episode for me and
I think that was really important I
think if they weren't able to hook you
emotionally and hook you just as like a
fan I don't think it would have had the
impact that it did and then of course
just the the lore building that it's
doing is is is so cool so yeah for me it
was for sure that first episode the most
important one in my opinion that really
hooked me yeah and and just the fact
that they could keep a reveal as giant
as there's a baby Yoda I don't know how
they did for us everybody as well you
still asked Dave filoni about it and he
just gets exasperated thinking about how
tough that was I don't know how they did
that and I think that's the most
impressive thing about the Star Wars
shows that they're doing you know with
movie even the movies to for the most
part they've done a pretty good job
keeping a lot of that stuff under wraps
I don't know how they do it and Marvel
has also done a fairly good job at doing
that as well I don't know how these
massive Productions are so good at
keeping these things under wraps I don't
know what their phone policy is on set I
don't know but I'm really happy about
that because as much as I love to talk
about this stuff and as much as I love
to do these like podcast shows and you
know we talk about movies and we do
reviews and I'm still really not
into spoiler talk before the movie comes
out like I don't necessarily want to
know everything
it's inevitable that someone will tweet
at me something that they read on a
forum that does end up being true
it's not that common and I always ask
people like hey look if you don't care
about spoilers that's fine yeah I like
to Res I like to hold on to the moment
as much as I can when I watch the thing
so I think that it's so impressive that
they've been able to hold all that stuff
back and I mean everything you look at
everything the Boba Fett reveal the
Ahsoka Tano stuff you know that stuff is
always room and room and rumored and
they just ignore it they don't address
it they don't bring attention to it none
of that stuff so it just they're really
able to kind of preserve the magic of
the experience which is I think
something that you know we had the
benefit of having
for me it was the prequel era obviously
because I wasn't alive when the original
trilogy came out but even though it was
a good time even those movies did a
great job of the prequels did a great
job of just kind of keeping everything
under wraps and of course it was a
different time we weren't on Twitter
like we are now but uh yeah so it's it's
really impressive that they're able to
really you know hold on to the or
preserve that first watch through
experience without things being spoiled
left and right and I would say the
headliner of that statement would be
Luke Skywalker because uh you know
you're ending ending a season and and
I'll never forget it's really one of the
great Star Wars viewing moments that I
had albeit it was virtual because my
brother uh two years younger than me is
up in Seattle and we just so happened to
be starting we were texting with each
other and we were just about to start
the final episode at the same time and
so we're like yeah let's just kind of
watch through this together and just
kind of you know chime in and he was he
was a little bit ahead of me and so I'm
watching it he didn't ruin it it was
Luke Skywalker but what he he texted me
he's like oh my God an X-Wing just
showed up and so if you know the scene
there's this big climactic kind of
Confrontation and then an X-Wing flies
in and docks inside this larger ship and
then who walks in but Mr green
lightsaber himself Luke Skywalker to
claim baby baby Yoda grogu to train and
when I saw the X-Wing when I saw my
brother's text I was still thinking that
it was though one of those two like sort
of Rebel cops that we met earlier in the
season and so I'm like okay well this is
cool I love seeing x-wings the Honda
Civic of outer space but and then I
started thinking like who else has it oh
my God no and then just the way that
they do the walk of Luke and then the
reveal that there's a green lightsaber
and seeing him I mean just with your
visual effects brain it it paid off for
me I mean obviously you know that it's
it's some sort of de-aging Technology
but it really looked good regardless of
what size screen it's on I mean in a
theater it would have looked at me
amazing but I really thought they pulled
it off well from a visual effects
standpoint yeah I had I obviously had
mixed I I don't I won't say I had mixed
feelings about it because I would say
it's like 90 of the way there I think
there's like 10 of like we're still
experimenting with this we don't know
exactly how to perfect it just yet but
we're getting there but I I I honestly
just kind of applaud them for even
trying it now in terms of like
how they've been using that technology
and sort of the justification of using
that technology and like the ethics of
that technology I think that's a
separate conversation but in terms of
like the quality of it I was really
impressed like it was off a little bit
but I you got to give it to them I mean
the fact that they went for it and they
were like you know what we feel
confident enough that people will buy
into Luke Skywalker being a part of the
story they'll be excited for it they'll
be so in the moment they'll be so
wrapped up in the moment the whether or
not it looks Pitch Perfect it is what it
is you know we'll make it better in the
next season because I I as soon as I saw
Luke Skywalker I thought okay if he's
taking baby Yoda grogu we're gonna see
this character again they're going to
work on this Tech and they're going to
make it even better for the next time
that we see him and the next time we see
him God it's so much better and yeah
it's unreal how how much better it got
in season two or in book a Boba Fett I
should say if there's a character in the
the Mandalorian that you say okay this
is this is somebody that I can latch my
wagon to as far as just a really
engaging story someone who I want to
come back week after week to see what
they are up to which character do you
say or is it just as simple as it is
watching the Mandalorian yeah it's for
sure watching the Mandalorian I think if
I don't think it's necessarily a bad
thing if it's um if it's baby Yoda if
it's grogu that's also fine but I think
if you're if you're not at all invested
in the Mandalorian story then I think
the show has failed but for me though I
it works incredibly well and I'm so
invested in benjarin and you know a
character who literally didn't exist
before three years ago and all it took
was you know those first eight I think
was eight episodes for me to be like I'm
fully invested I love this character I
love Pedro Pascal and I love that he
does The Voice
so I just was I don't know I don't know
what it was I think it was not not even
the fact that he looked like another
Boba Fett type of character I think it's
just the way they wrote the mystery
about the story and the way they slowly
unravel things and how he becomes a part
of sort of like the Mandalorian culture
and all that sort of stuff I think they
just wrote a character who and because
it is Dave filoni and and it's John
Favreau particularly Dave filoni because
he is such a Star Wars fan I think that
was the key part to making that show
work so yeah for me dinjarin for sure is
like and even now even with bookaboba
Fett with the Ahsoka show happening
whatever future stories they tell that
are in this like five-year post-return
of the Jedi to me denjarin is always
going to be the anchor that as long as
his story is kind of firing on all
cylinders and he's the thing that's kind
of grounding the whole you know this
whole second phase of Storytelling in
the seek in the pre in the original
trilogy era then I'm gonna be on board
with almost whatever they do
and and getting to see mandalorian's
battle I believe Deborah chow and it's
probably the reason why she's my
favorite uh director that's working on
these right now yeah and all due respect
to your favors to uh Rick family you was
there isn't a bad one in the bunch but
watching Deborah chow and how she had
that action scene where we're using our
jet packs in in season one and it's just
this great old west shootout it's just
so well done I think that was episode
three and that's the one where we we
were we were going along we're setting
up this world what the the status of the
Galaxy is and then we get the Star Wars
action that we all crave and so that was
so well done by her as far as characters
from me go I would go with I could
easily watch an entire run with fennec
who has been played by Ming Na Wen who's
just such great connective tissue
between the Mandalorian and book of Boba
Fett
um and then obviously grief just because
it's Carl Weathers and and he can't go
wrong with Apollo baby you cannot go
wrong with Apollo Creed he directed
himself a wonderful episode oh the
absolutely director was so cool seeing
those Stormtroopers on those on those um
on those speeder bikes I was like damn
yeah where are you being this whole time
Carl Weathers and you know obviously I
have a soft spot for Mayfield just
because it's played by my my buddy Bill
Burr who is uh you know they set Twitter
on fire for a day because God forbid we
have a Bostonian in space who talks like
a Bostonian and I you know I do a bit
about it I want to see a whole planet of
Boston you know I want them I I just I
want nothing but Boston if it's not
called Bostonia then don't do it
it was a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away just I want them to narrate the
whole thing it'd be wonderful to read
the crawl text with a Boston accent but
I'm so interested in this time period as
far as uh who's getting ahead who's
making a buck here who's getting a leg
up with there's fragments of the Empire
the Rebellion still finding its footing
and I go to Werner Herzog the client
that is such a fascinating character to
me I want that movie I just want to know
how this guy got here with his dealings
with the Empire with the boots on the
ground he always has a plan he's always
got some he's always got these loose
ends that need to be tied up and I just
find him such an interesting character
that you could just delve into that
backstory for days and that's the kind
of thing that I wanted in this show and
so where I feel like the Mandalorian
certainly you're tuning in every week to
see where we're going on this road trip
adventure with Mandalorian and grogu but
man there's a lot of good supporting
casts in the Mandalorian as well oh
absolutely and I would very much like to
see that movie
yeah and I think that that is um that to
me is one of the things that was a bit
unexpected for me when it came to the
Mandalorian was
how much I was intrigued by the
supporting characters how much more of
the supporting characters I wanted to
see how many of those supporting
characters I was just like you I'm like
I would love to see a movie about that
girl I'd love to see a show about that I
would love to see you know like Amy
sedaris's character I never would have
thought in a million years I would care
about this character in Maz espa but
here we are and I'm like I'd be super
intrigued to find out about her
relationship with Jawas tell me more
please there's just so and that that to
me is like the magic of Mando is that
yes you care about dingarn yes you care
about grogu but you care about everyone
like all the characters that you were
just listening you care about all of
them you care about all of them the show
made you care about Boba Fett in a way
that you never cared about before you
thought he looked cool you thought the
idea and concept of Boba Fett was cool
but Mandalorian showed you oh
this is why people talk about him the
way they do and why they talk about why
he's so cool yeah I agree and I think
that's the magic of what they're doing
is they could spin off literally any
character and for the most part I think
people would be like I'm on board I'm on
board I'm on board to see what this
character is all about and I think
that's so cool that they have that sort
of trust with the audience but they also
have the confidence to just say yeah why
not let's just do it why not well it's I
guess coincidental that we're talking
about these shows in anticipation of the
Cassie and Andor series that's about to
drop because Cassie and Andor when we
see him in Rogue one is really one of
the First characters in Star Wars I
think you could point to where you
actually feel and see the desperation of
the time and you forgive a character
like Andor for using extreme methods
just to survive we're more we give more
moral ground to them because we know
that they're an impossible situations
like when you have to shoot somebody
that you know in the back and whereas we
can imagine Han Solo will probably
getting into some hairy situations in
his past in the classic Trilogy I never
saw it so viscerally portrayed until it
was casting and or then we get a lot of
these characters we're talking about in
the Mandalorian that like look they're
out to survive okay so they may not
necessarily be the most trustworthy
individuals but it's because that's how
desperate the times are on the flip side
of that Obi-Wan Kenobi doesn't get that
luxury because we know him just to be
the purest of the pure and we've trusted
him for so long with movies that bookend
the series Obi-Wan Kenobi and so do you
feel like that character lived up to how
we saw him in the prequels and in the
classic Trilogy going into the show as
soon as I sort of heard like you know
the log line or whatever where it was
like he's he's someone who's really
pushed the past away and he's trying to
just live out his hermit life on
Tatooine I thought this is going to be
very reminiscent of Luke's journey in
the Last Jedi I think people are not
gonna like it but to me it kind of feels
like a natural progression to where that
character should be now obviously by the
end of the series I figured he would
kind of be in a different place but yeah
I mean you know does he live up to the
expectation I mean it kind of depends on
what your expectation is so kind of like
with the Luke Skywalker thing people
were expecting to see a certain type of
Luke Skywalker they wanted to see
probably a version of the character that
existed at that point in the expanded
universe where he was this all-knowing
wise Jedi and he was powerful and he
could do all these things
so I think with Obi-Wan Kenobi I kind of
went into it with the thought process of
well what has this character already
been through how does that affect where
he's currently at and what do those
events that are he's currently about to
go through affect how he is in the
future so from that perspective it was a
little bit easier for me to kind of
grasp with the idea of an Obi-Wan Kenobi
who is not the same Obi-Wan Kenobi from
the prequel era where he's a little bit
more light-hearted and he's a little bit
more has this like energy to him and
he's quippy and he's fun this is a guy
who pretty much had to kill his brother
more or less to prevent the rise of a
terrible regime Across the Universe it
led to the death of friends colleagues
you know
at so many allies it led to the
destruction of of a republic that he
believed in in values that he believed
in so it wasn't surprising to me that
when we meet this character he is really
just like living his days until the day
that he no longer exists and it's really
you know it's the events of that show
that kind of pull him back into the
story so I I think once we get into the
story and once we start progressing and
he finds out that Anakin is alive and
then he's Darth Vader and there's all
these things that start to you know the
the ball starts to get bigger as it
rolls down the hill the snowball he
starts to kind of lean back into the
things that we loved about him in the
prequels he starts to become once again
that hero that protector that Defender
that Guardian of the Galaxy that we kind
of know him as and he starts to kind of
like loosen up and he starts to become
quippy again but then you know there's
emotional moments where he has to
confront Darth Vader and those feelings
that he has those emotions come back
into play so I think there's a lot
there's a big emotional role coaster for
that character but I do think that by
the time we get to the end of that show
it leans a little bit more back into the
alleghenis version of that character and
then you know there's still eight years
of unexplored territory whether or not
we see that in a show who knows you know
but I I so I do think that it does kind
of like honor the bookends of that story
of the prequel version where we see him
where he's a little bit more
light-hearted
he goes through some trauma he deals
with that trauma and then by the end of
it he's a little bit more he's just a
little closer to the alleghenis version
without being so close that you're like
well what difference is what's the
difference between this character from
the end of this first season to the
beginning of a new Hub because I feel
like if he felt too similar to the
alligunous version that I'm like well
what did he do for eight years
you know yeah right yeah if it's too
close you know it'd be different if the
show ended and then two weeks later the
events of A New Hope happened I'm like
okay yeah that's fine but eight years
I'm like people changed so much in eight
years that's that's the amount of time
I've been making YouTube content if I
haven't changed in the entire eight
years that I've been making stuff then
there's something I don't know I'm
missing out on something I think and
much like Obi once look in this show I'm
sure fans are just livid that you still
look as young as you do and I'll just
remind people that Obi-Wan still has
like Adam said eight years to just run
out of sunscreen and just get his his
field match again there's not just one
there's two sons on Tatooine okay and so
you need an SPF 1000 if you want to stay
out of that stuff it's a hot hot desert
dry planet and I I love the the
connective line that you drew between
Obi-Wan as we see him in the series and
Luke Skywalker as we meet him in the
Last Jedi because they both had this
ideal this utopian Vista of what the the
Galaxy could have looked like and when
you know really it was part of their
shortcomings that you don't necessarily
blame them for it but they also they
were the line of defense and it didn't
work out and so they just go into hiding
whether it's Forest whether it's just
emotionally that's the only place left
for them to go and the thing that I that
I said when the Obi-Wan series was
announced and you know they look back on
it and we always you can change our
opinions but I said I didn't necessarily
want or need Darth Vader in the show
because I wanted to just watch Obi-Wan
exist and maybe get into some squabbles
on Tatooine and have to figure something
out and then they announced Hayden
Christensen is back and you get excited
because it is Darth Vader and you always
love seeing Darth Vader in his prime but
the Vader aspect of the show did that
live up to the the sort of hype that you
had for it do you feel like this was a
different baiter that you met or was it
consistent with the Vader that you've
come to know and if not love respect
yeah and I think again you know talking
about transitions I think that's what
the show
for me at least kind of felt like and I
don't think at the time when it was
announced that was what I was looking
for but as we went on the journey that's
what it kind of ended up being for me as
a transitional point because before we
even see Vader again and you hope we see
him in Rebels we see him in all kinds of
stuff and you know I know that not every
Star Wars fan you know binges every
piece of Star Wars media and that's
totally fine
um but you know but for me I've seen
Rebels I've seen shades of what happens
to that character right before we meet
him again and you hope his interactions
with Ahsoka and all that sort of stuff
so for me this Vader in particular even
though it is 10 years sort of into his
tenure as this villain
still feel like he is dealing with the
trauma and the emotional damage that
he's been through uh you know leading up
to all of these events so I think for
him to sort of still struggle to not
only deal with how he feels about
everything that's happening to him and
how everything's sort of all the events
are kind of circling around him
but also just dealing with his internal
struggle of how to cope with am I Anakin
Skywalker or am I Darth Vader what does
that mean what's the difference between
Anakin Skywalker and Darth Vader what's
the difference between the Anakin
Skywalker I became
you know right before I became Darth
Vader and then What's the diff like you
know how how is he juggling that idea of
dealing with his identity because that
to me feels like something that if you
went through that Journey like he does
yes you're going to be emotionally
damaged because of everything that you
went through but also
what yeah like what identity do you
Embrace what does it mean to be Darth
Vader what is that what is that yeah
yeah that we get is seeing Obi-Wan and
Anakin training and how Obi-Wan still
has the upper hand when it comes to the
mental games that a Jedi must play and
to see Darth Vader still sometimes fall
prey to his old Master when it comes to
that but you make such a fascinating
point because the Darth Vader that you
get to see in a new hope this is a more
advanced more comfortable in his own
boots Darth Vader than even the one that
we get in the Obi-Wan streaming series
and you know I I gotta tell you you know
Darth Vader's in this show and so then
every other villain I just in my idiot
brain just kind of reduced to a cookie
cutter villain until they prove
something different to me and so you
have Rupert Rupert Friend is a grand
Inquisitor and then you have uh Moses
Ingram as Inquisitor Riva and so where I
just thought they were just going to be
stock kind of one node they're they're
just the bad guy eyes then riva's
storyline I think is so important and
really shows where Star Wars has
progressed from A New Hope in 1977 where
you had okay we're good and we're bad
and this Han Solo guy he's right but
he's gonna be a good guy with Riva it's
just as evil as it can get but then you
also see why and you see you talk about
the emotional damage that was dealt to
her as a young Wing it's the same sort
of thing that you get with John boyega's
Finn in in force awakens because he's a
stormtrooper and that's sort of what
he's been trained and he didn't really
have a choice in the matter as to what
his life path was so to see characters
more recently in Star Wars lore begin at
Point a and then sort of take control of
Their Own Destiny for the very first
time is really really I think an
interesting facet of Storytelling that I
hope we continue to see in Star Wars
going forward I think also with just
expanding that lore like you're saying I
think that it makes it more interesting
if you can find a way to use characters
where they are struggling with identity
they're struggling to figure out what
their place is in the world because we
do that on a daily basis it doesn't
matter right now yeah it doesn't matter
if you're 20 25 35 45 you're constantly
trying to figure out am I doing the
right thing am I on the right path
should I go left should I go right
should I go backwards which way should I
go you're constantly doing that and I
think that's what makes the Star Wars
lore feel that much more
three-dimensional is when we when we
project those issues those real life
issues that we deal with onto those
characters and find interesting ways to
then carve out their story in the
universe and that to me is what is so
intriguing and exciting about this new
era of Star Wars is that we can do that
we can do that with characters like Riva
hell we could make a whole show about
the inquisitors and talk about their
relationships with each other their
relationships with Darth Vader their
relationships with the emperor with the
rest of the Empire itself with the
entire galaxy like that's what I think
is so cool is that you can do these
things now and make really layered
characters and everyone who watches can
kind of find the character that kind of
speaks to them the most whether or not
they're a good or bad I think like even
the villains
at some point must have been good and
they were set on a path that led them
somewhere and it's like oh you can
always find things that kind of reflect
or mirror something in our life that
we've done that we're like oh yeah I
made a questionable make a questionable
Choice here like this character did cool
now I know how bad that is I'm not going
to do that again unless it's murder then
I'm like you should have probably known
that beforehand you probably should have
known that already yeah you look at the
book of Boba Fett and you say did did
this show live up
to we couldn't help ourselves with the
expectations as to who Boba Fett was did
he survive the sarlac pit at all do you
think that this lived up to the
expectations that you yourself had for
Boba Fett's future should he get out of
the sarlacc pit for me it more than
exceeded what I thought would happen
afterwards yeah I was actually very
surprised by the show especially I would
say the first like two three episodes I
think were the most surprising to me
because we dive into how did he survive
the sarlacc bit how did he integrate
himself with the tuscans and all that
sort of stuff that to me I was just so
mind blown by that that was such a a
pleasantly unexpected curveball you know
and the way that they communicate it for
me what it did is it took a character
that was really nothing if you think
about it he was nothing he looked really
cool and that's fine that's totally fine
if the character looks cool but what the
book of boba fed did
for that character is something that I
wish that the prequels would have done
that we didn't really get to because he
shows up in one movie as a kid we make
his dad look really cool but then we
never see or hear from him in episode
three which I think was a lost
opportunity so I think what what book
above a Fed did for sure was it allowed
us to learn more about the character
learn about the struggles and again
talking about sort of that emotional
damage he has that one sequence where he
has this vision of everything that's
kind of happened throughout his life the
trauma that he's been through of
constantly seeing his father go off on
these missions and being left alone on
kamino and you know like that has to
have some sort of an impact on you when
that's constantly the thing that you're
exposed to and I think that was the
thing that surprised me the most was
the fact that yes he's a bounty hunter
yes he's badass looking but there is a a
human element to this character who is a
clone of another character he's you know
he was birthed out of Technology but to
see that this character has his own his
own feelings and thoughts and he has his
own trauma it makes you just that much
more attached to the character and and
to to I guess brief you know new life
into the the perspective of what the
tuscans are and who they are and to have
those interactions between those two
groups of people was so cool and then of
course having him team up with uh with
fenikshend was awesome come on yeah and
as soon as come on when they ran that
little tease the Stinger at the end of
Mandalorian and it was book of Boba Fett
and then he sits down on the throne but
then she comes in next to him that's
where I was like yeah I am totally yep
all in on this show and you know with
with Boba Fett and with Mandalorian we
don't necessarily know where those
stories go where they're going to end
with Obi-Wan we did I mean we've seen
the movies we know what ultimately
happens to Obi-Wan in this life and the
next Cassie and andor's show Andor which
drops September 21st that is one where
again we know the end of this character
but seeing their beginning is this one
that you that you had earmarked for a
while is this one where do you think the
sky's the limit this maybe could be the
best of the streaming series thus far I
will tell you that trailer blew me away
both trailers you know I think the
latest trailer gave us a lot more I'm
just so impressed with the the visuals
of that show and they're not using the
volume on that show at all it's
exclusively done on sets and on location
and what exactly is the volume the so
the volume is this led technology that
they've been using on Mandalorian Boba
Fett and Obi-Wan Kenobi it's basically
170 degree set of LED screens and they
can project any background they want
onto it and capture in camera without
having to do any sort of compositing to
remove the greens screen remove the blue
screen but they do still obviously have
the option of projecting blue or green
in case they want to make changes in in
the um in the future I think that
technology has worked incredibly well on
the Mandalorian series I think it worked
for the most part really well on Boba
Fett I think with Obi-Wan Kenobi is a
little bit of a hit and miss sometimes I
felt like it made the scale of the show
feel a lot smaller at times so I think
that was the thing that got me excited
about Andor was it felt like the scale
was back to a larger size on a more
cinematic level in a lot of ways to what
we're used to with Rogue one and the
solo spin-off movies obviously The Saga
films are gonna are gonna look that way
um so I think that was the thing that
impressed me the most was just the
visual quality of of what the show looks
like and then of course Diego Luna is so
charming and Cassie nandor was obviously
like one of the best characters of Rogue
one but I'm also really excited I think
for a lot of the themes that I hope it
dives into the politicalness of Star
Wars the political dramaness of Star
Wars is really exciting to me and that
is built into the DNA of Star Wars
whether people want to admit that or not
that's just part of it it's always been
a part of it no matter what so I'm
really excited to see mon mothma first
of all a character who was in a deleted
scene in episode three and then had one
scene Return of the Jedi to now see what
is who is this character who's this
character amongst the Republic who's his
character in relationship to the Rebel
Alliance that's slowly growing I'm
excited to see how that character is
woven in and what her journey is and
what her story is and I actually like
the fact that this show is only two
seasons it's 24 episodes the second
season we know is kind of like every few
episodes is a year leading up to Rogue
one and then it ends with Rogue one that
to me is cool because yes I know where
that character goes but I'm all about
the journey the journey to me is the
exciting part and seeing you know
sagarrera seeing some of these
characters return will probably see more
characters show up from Star Wars Lord I
like that because not only does it give
us more about Cassian Andor or but it
just continues to build out that era of
Star Wars which honestly I was not that
excited about when they kept saying
we're gonna make stuff in between
episodes three and four I'm like don't
we kind of already know what's happening
we need to see more of this stuff can't
we focus on time periods that like we
don't know anything about
but they've just done such a good job
with Rebels and all these shows building
out what's happened in you know those
like 18ish years in between that I'm
like you know what I was wrong let's see
what Andor can do and what what does
that show add to the lore in that time
period there's probably way more stuff
that we can do because it's true that
universe is massive it's very excited
for it it's a big Galaxy but the million
dollar question is this as as we sort of
close the book on Boba Fett and Obi-Wan
and the Mandalorian for now anyways we
anticipate Andor if I make you Adam if I
put you in Kathleen Kennedy's seat I
give you Dave filoni's Fedora what is
the Star Wars show that you want to make
that's an excellent question see for me
I I love what they're doing but I would
love to see someone ballsy enough to go
a thousand years into the future of Star
Wars and make something okay maybe it
doesn't even have to be a thousand we
can go 100 and 150 years into the future
what is sort of the ripple effect of
defeating the first order defeating the
Empire rebuilding potentially the Jedi
Order how does Rey do it differently
than Luke is it thriving is it
succeeding what does it look like is the
Republic rebuilt you know those are
things that I would like to explore how
how has it changed because I kind of
look at the way I reflected to our world
how has our world changed since
traumatic events like World War II you
know World War like all these things
that we've that we've dealt with and
fought you know how has the world
changed how has it evolved For Better or
For Worse so I would like to see someone
do that you know I I know that we love
to go and explore the past because
there's already material being built
around that but go 100 100 years 150
years in the future what is the Jedi the
new Jedi Order look like what does the
what is the political landscape of Star
Wars look like in that future
um I think that would be really really
fascinating it's intriguing yeah you you
think about the fall of Rome you think
about the fall of Constantinople you
think about these life is seismic shifts
in the history of of Earth sense humans
have been around I mean the sky really
is the limit I've always said I really
want to go back to the Old Republic I
want to see the foundation of it I love
that movies like Rogue one sort of
hinted at what was before with these
Fallen statues and and ancient temples
so there's a lot of things to do I'm
excited for Andor as well but I'm also
excited to go to a completely different
time period and just see what the hell
is going on could we see the original
Yoda back in his younger days wearing a
varsity jacket as he learns the ways of
the force so I'm all in all him I am in
all I am it's uh it's it's a
never-ending source of conversation
between me my friends and I'm sure are
listeners and our viewers and your pals
as well is what have we gotten in Star
Wars what do we love and what are we
excited for the future So Adam you're
always such a fun guy to talk to you're
an easy guy to talk to yet you're so
much more knowledgeable about this stuff
so I don't know how you manage to keep
keep your intelligence and your
approachability in sort of kismet spirit
with one another but thank you for once
again joining us here where can
everybody out there in the world find
you and at least the show that looks
like on camera you guys are the best of
friends regardless of what arguments may
be happening backstage uh well first of
all thank you so much for having me Mark
I I love any opportunity I get to talk
to you about literally anything whether
it's California Burritos beers or movies
it's it's always a fun time so thank you
so much I really appreciate you having
me on as far as where you can find me my
social media is very easy I'm a very
lazy person when it comes to social
media it's just my name Adam labik you
can check me out on Heroes reforged on
YouTube we do a podcast called the
checks against where we just we just
kind of talk about whatever we want to
talk about especially corporate mergers
and how it affects the properties that
we love uh we're also doing reactions
for a ton of shows including all the
Star Wars stuff we'll be doing Andor as
well check that out and uh yeah I love I
love hanging out and talking about
movies so anytime you want to have me on
just let me know I think you know we
usually do a TV or movie streaming
recommendations all that stuff but I
think both of us would go ahead and take
a leap of faith and say y'all should go
check out Andor because it looks like
you're going to get something pretty
damn good and then Mandalorian season
three coming up and you have I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
content that stars is putting out in
show form that I don't know when we're
getting more movies but in the meantime
these shows are are keeping my Star Wars
appetite at Bay
um so we'll check out Andor on September
21st and so for everybody here
Jacqueline Coley who is currently
working hard on assignment Brian Perez
producing Lucy Tim Ryan and the whole
gang at Rotten Tomatoes I am merely Mark
Ellis saying not hello there because I'm
parting ways with you so I'll simply say
the force will be with you always
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you